mais l'état cela fait près de vingt ans
que les docteurs côté et poirier ont
fondé la clinique du quartier latin ou
centre ville de montréal
ils ont choisi de pratiquer en milieu
urbain le concept médecine urbaine où on
orientait des soins par rapport à une
clientèle qui fréquente le centre denis
clientèles vulnérables de personnes
texte commun une personne itinérante
on est ample et du village aujourd'hui
cette clientèle vulnérable constitue
presque la moitié des patientes se gmf
groupe de médecine familiale au fil des
ans il s'est spécialisé dans le
traitement du sida et des maladies
transmises sexuellement avec des
patients qui doivent consulter plusieurs
fois par année et le système de santé on
a longtemps tenu compte
on avait très bien reconnu que certaines
cartel entre autres la clientèle
séropositives un patient séropositif
comptait pour plusieurs patients
un patient séropositif comptait pour 4
patients une femme enceinte pour 7 avec
ce calcul cette pondération
la clinique a soigné pendant dix ans
l'équivalent de quinze mille personnes
par année
elle a si bien respecté son contrat avec
l'état quel reçu une lettre la
qualifiant de super performant d' la
convention no jail respecter et
renouveler la cime d'inscription
clientèle inscrits est atteint l'offre
de services je ne cours toutes les 1
avec les félicitations le gmf a reçu des
ressources supplémentaires il ya un an
et demi
mais quelques mois plus tard avant les
élections la pondération a été annulé on
n'a cessé de reconnaître sa clientèle
particulière on nous demande de créer
gmf un peu atypique et apprécions en
asie faute
et là c'est plus jamais pareil ça des
records de cette particularité
du jour au lendemain la clientèle de la
clinique tombe de 15000 à 9000 patients
aux yeux du ministère 40 % des sommes
dédié à l'administration et au personnel
infirmier sont coupées on a déjà
commencé à couper des services par
exemple on avait une nutritionniste qui
était fourni parle pas par l' agence on
avait une kinésiologue on avait une
travailleuse sociale on était coupé dans
ses services au plus sans faire de la
vienne dix ans maxime à ses pertes de
financement et de personnel s'ajoute
maintenant les quotas de patients que le
nouveau ministre de la santé veut
imposer aux médecins et s'accentue
notent problème les coupures avant
pénaliser plus la clinique elle même
mais le fait d'établir de vouloir
établir des quotas
ça pénalise ça pénalise vraiment les
médecins le docteur côté pass 3 jours
par semaine à la clinique qu'il doit
administrer en plus d'y soigner 750
patients
il passe les deux autres jours au chum
le coq kg moi ça me va la voir ma
coupure parce que je pense pas que je
vois capable de doubler à moins de
renoncer au travail à l'hôpital et il
n'y a pas de logique à le faire si
j'abandonne d'état siens pour un
pensionné d'autres outils créés ailleurs
sinon il leur faudrait donner moins de
temps à leurs patients ce qui irait à
l'encontre de leur éthique
professionnelle
nous ça nous intéresse pas de faire une
médecine de mcdo on n'élit pas à passer
à comolli une radiographie du poumon 5
secondes on va pondéreuses le ministre a
beau avoir promis qu'il tiendrait compte
de la complexité de certains cas ces
médecins en doute
mais nice le 10 le public j'ai bien vu
des cris et dans le contexte de
confiance qui est pas optimal
actuellement je préférerais voir des
choses écrites
l'ouverture est pas si grande que ça à
mon avis il y a parlé d'une parler d'une
pondération possible pour les patients
pauvres toxicomanes avec des problèmes
de santé mentale
plusieurs autres vulnérabilités et je le
pense je veux surtout pas négliger
celle-là et c'en est une
une bonne partie de la clientèle que je
vois mais c'est beaucoup plus large que
ça soupçonne le ministre de vouloir
faire des économies sur le dos des
médecins qui ont des patients
vulnérables
sachant qu'ils ne voudront pas les
abandonner je pense que le ministre est
très bien ce qu'il fait et ce
est ce parce que ce qui n'existe une
baisse de salaire c'est l'avenir même de
leur clinique qui est en jeu les dr
poirier écouter son paquet pour leurs
patients